Leprosy is one of those things from movies
and stories, except when it's not and you
get it.
Like if you lick and armadillo.
Seriously.
True story.
Hey guys, Trace here for DNews.
Most of us have heard of leprosy.
You probably associate it with colonies of
lepers with missing limbs that haven’t been
seen since the time of Jesus, but in reality
it’s still around today.
More than 200,000 cases appear every year
around the world, yet few of us know much
about the disease beyond its dramatic history.
So sit tight, because we’re about to clear
a few things up.
First off, its official name is Hansen’s
Disease, after the scientist who discovered
its causative agent, Mycobacterium leprae.
This bacteria spreads mostly through direct
contact with saliva or mucus.
But also through certain animals, such as
armadillos, which have an ideal body temperature
to keep the bacteria alive.
So, contrary to widespread belief, leprosy
is actually not very infectious.
And those who are unlucky enough to contract
the disease often go years before seeking
treatment, as the bacteria reproduces very
slowly, and symptoms can take anywhere from
five to 20 years to develop.
That means you could have leprosy right now
and not even know it!
But you probably don’t have leprosy.
In fact, about 95 percent of the population
is immune to it.
And in the unlikely event that you do contract
the disease, there’s still hope.
Scientists discovered a cure in the 1940’s,
and since 1995, a multi-drug treatment has
been provided to leprosy patients around the
world free of cost.
After treatment begins, the disease is usually
gone within 6 to 12 months.
And in the last two decades more than 16 million
people have been cured this way.
Still, hundreds of thousands of new cases
pop up every year, mostly in subtropical regions
of Africa, Asia, Central and South America.
The poor are particularly susceptible, as
lack of nutritious food, sanitation and medical
care leads to the spread of disease.
As a result, leprosy is much more common in
developing nations, such as India, which is
home to at least 60 percent of all infected
people.
Here in the United States, leprosy is extremely
rare, with less than 200 cases a year.
Although the disease is not deadly, it can
have serious implications, especially for
the victim’s appearance.
Left untreated, the bacteria spreads through
the skin and the peripheral nerves, manifesting
in pale or red lesions and sores as well as
numbness in the extremities.
Because they can no longer feel pain in their
hands and feet, people with leprosy are much
more prone disabling injuries or secondary
infections, which would often require amputation.
This would explain leprosy’s inaccurate
reputation as being ‘flesh eating’, causing
one’s body parts to simply fall off.
Because of their appearance, people with leprosy
have been stigmatized.
From biblical times all the way up to the
end of the 20th century, most people suspected
of having leprosy were forced into exile,
resulting in thousands of so-called leper
colonies.
Although governments stopped this practice
by the beginning of the 20th century, many
leprosy patients, particularly those who do
not have access to treatment, continue to
quarantine themselves, fearing ostracism from
their community.
This is one of the reasons leprosy continues
to plague certain countries.
Discrimination and stigma leads to shame,
and this actually prevents people from seeking
treatment -- which of course, leads to further
spread of the disease.
So perhaps the best way to eradicate leprosy
is actually just to get rid of the stigmas
around it.
Seriously, ask yourself: What Would Jesus
Do?
Now you know more about leprosy you should
check out this video from her sister show
seeker daily where they explore what happens
to people who
HAVE leprosy.
You might think leper colonies are a thing
of the past…
Watch that video here.
What do you guys think about all this?
Did it change you mind on what leprosy really
is?
Let us know in the comments and keeping coming
back for more DNews.